on va mettre dedans d'accord
un atelier de bouturage dans un lieu
insolite le 30 septembre dernier une
quinzaine d'associations du territoire
Yves Linois organisé la fête des
possibles dans le centre commercial au
shopping de plaisir pour rencontrer les
gens on pense qu'un samedi est dans une
galerie commerciale il peut y avoir
beaucoup de gens à voir effectivement
les gens voilà on peut interpeller les
gens dans leur acte quotidien de
consommation on en entend parler tous
les jours sur dans les actualités la
crise climatique est là donc ce qu'on
veut montrer aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a
des solutions on peut faire à notre
niveau de citoyens le but de cette fête
rendre visible les initiatives
citoyennes une démarche qui a convaincu
le centre commercial aujourd'hui chacun
doit se soucier aussi de l'avenir social
écologique de la planète et ça rentre
vraiment sur la stratégie en fait RSE
que l'entreprise nude et stress
gestionnaire et propriétaire du des
centres commerciaux souhaite développer
répare café conseil pour réduire ses
déchets Do It Yourself entretien de vélo
et les associations proposées divers
ateliers tout au long de la journée la
perceuse va malheureusement elle est
réparable donc ils font pas de miracle
mais c'est essayer et la deuxième le PC
bah ils ont trouvé le problème en deux
petits coups de soudure ils m'ont réparé
mon PC et maintenant il refonctionne
nickel la fête des possibles
s'inscrivait dans le cadre de la Semaine
européenne du développement durable qui
dure elle jusqu'au 8 octobre prochain